leading your team out onto a field
especially in a in a big game when you
know you're going to have a sellout
crowd
that is quite a thrill for any pitcher
anthony schofani on the hill tonight for
the giants making start number 26 11-6
on the year with a three eight era
127 strikeouts 36 walks for the six foot
195 pound right hander who's 31 years
he's in his eighth year at the big
league level trey turner the hitter
stepping in for the dodgers
base head to right field on a two-strike
pitch
so here is max muncie
crawford hustles gets one
and off the back and hits the runner and
it ricochets over to the screen along
the side crawford had nobody to throw
the ball to mookie betts 269 and
in an injury-plagued year he's got 19
home runs and 25 doubles
and a pop-up
belt backing up foul ground
got him on a 2-0 pitch well hitting a
walk in this inning for the dodgers
against d scuffany and here's corey
seeger two balls two strikes two on two
out
he struck him out the inning is over
slider got him that was a great pitch
could be a bullpen game for the dodgers
and cory knebel the first man to take it
he's had a few starts and this is very
comfortable in this starting position
last time he started which wasn't his
last outing but the one before he faced
the minimum got
five outs gave up a hit but got a double
play
down the right field line base hit
mookie bets
unlike most right fielders in this
ballpark was not way over in the right
center the dodgers align their offer a
little bit differently here enables 2-2
pitch is a curve to get him swinging
one guard here in the first and a
strikeout of brendon bell
four straight curveballs to begin now
fast spot that he pops up
here's the dugout monsieur has room and
brian is out number two
can't give up on a pop-up in san
francisco the wind is going to do all
kinds of stuff with it that ball
probably was going to be out of play
wind blowing out to right
he swings and grounds it to first
backhanded by muncie steps on the bag
and the inning is over no runs one hit
one left through one
no score giants will take out number two
but turner in scoring position with
mookie betts as the hitter 2-0 to mookie
betts the pitch
is hit to right center field sprinting
over his yostremski he'll get there and
make the catch
for out number three huge moment still
very early in this game slater who just
homered yesterday his tenth of the year
stands in against vicia bases loaded one
out
that is a base hit
dee stefani will score rough over to
third on a two-strike count he gets the
big hit for the first run of the night
boy i mean that is just an
0-2 gift i mean he comes right at him
with a fastball and it is on a tee and
hitters brandon crawford singled his
first time the 1-1
fly ball center field bellinger going
back he'll crack it down and that will
end the inning giants come up with one
run two hits
leave three
radaroll is the fourth pitcher already
used by the dodgers and we're just
starting the fourth inning swinging the
ground ball right along the first base
line of fair ball headed down the right
field line it bounces off the sidewalk
it's bare-handed then by mookie betts
who's got a great arm the throw to
second is offline
sliding in head first a second with a
double
is tyrone estrada
sharply hit grinder right past the first
base bag and hit that angled sidewall
that comes right out near the stands
and so it's up to darren ruff who has
reached both top single in the first
inning walk in the third
straw to the third with two gone and
ruff bounces it back to him
and that will do it for the giants in
the fourth
and once again with two outs they put a
runner in score position
here's the pitch
ball four posey takes a walk giants have
two on with two outs ryder slider
slaughter that's gonna be it for shane
green it's playoff game might as well be
so justin brewer will face his hometown
team for the first time what a setting
night for him he may have a lot of
family and friends in attendance he's
from petaluma and he comes out in a big
spot here against brandon crawford
with thomas
off the end of the back to third
turner's got it
so the giants leave two more on they
have stranded eight men on base in
five innings the one away muncie still
at first estrada also pulled in a bit
double played death and there's a ground
ball in it to short not hit hard
crawford has it the second one and
estrada first two
a double play
tyro estrada
stayed in there made the relay throw
just as muncie was about to plow into
him and put it right on the bag and die
sclerfati has given the giants
six strong against the dodgers
hard hit diving stab at third by turner
his low throw kicks off the glove of
muncie
and eva longoria will reach with two
outs you know that that's kind of a
tough play for for muncie because
throwing it hard it would have been an
easier time
of bounce to try and make a catch up if
you're muncie but
the slow speed came up and those are
tough that gets staring rough to the
play with the man on and two gone here
in the six
swatted to center bellinger
looked like that bounce
they're gonna say that he caught it
giants are asking them to take a look to
be enough to overturn it so it is a hit
for daryn ruff
swing and there's a high pop foul off
the third base side
turner the third baseman comes over he's
got room and he makes the catch
and belt is going on one pinch
left center field on the run
slater gets there
nice play
aj pollock was convinced i'm sure that
that was going to be extra bases
down in the direction of 399 in left
center field and austin slater
made the play
one nothing giants
crawford left center field hit well that
one is way back there off the wall
taylor comes up throwing crawford with a
double
it's a lead-off double in the eighth
inning for brandon crawford one two
pitch here it comes costella
on one hop to third over to his left to
scoop it up justin turner spins around
and throws him out
he just robbed la stella
one of the second time in the game that
the dodgers have gotten a runner as far
as third base here's the pitch
it is hit hard to second estrada's got
it coming home with the ball turner's
caught on a rundown posey running in
back and buster posey's just going to
keep running that way he will tag
both runners and it's seeger is going to
be out now cozy lunges for seeger
but seeger was the guy who was out
turner was off the bag by a half step
and posey had a chance to get the final
out of the game one more chance and it
belongs to chris taylor two on two out
one one
taylor lines it into center field it's
down for a base head they've tied it
down to their last breath so bueller is
now at third base another one-two pitch
turner serves it into center this will
get the job done bueller comes in to
score on a sacrifice fly from trey
turner the jacks will have to get buster
posey home if they're going to stay
alive in this one 2-1 10th inning
crawford
up the middle base hit
buster's gonna be waved
taylor comes up throwing
sleeve and crawford goes to second on
the throw
and then i'll get another strikeout
situation with a runner third less than
two outs
to crawford he's gonna go home posey's
tag and he's out what a throw by
crawford tell you what to have the guts
to do that brandon bell the possible
winning run at third buster trying to
bring his old friend belt home here
here's the pitch buster hits a shot
towards second over to field at turner
spins around throws it first and he
pulled will smith off the bag posey's
safe
and the winning run is scored
he is safe and the game is over
giants have won three to two